good and thanks for joining us today on
the science lab we're going to be
talking about toxins in our environment
we focusing on lead and da have three
experts with us today and Samantha then
return boss besides she is an expert on
blending soil we also have mark progress
I toxicologists and we also have just
Justin teegarden who studies beauty a
effects on top so let's get going I
thought we would start today by just
explaining the difference between EPA
and let they're very different kinds of
chemicals that efficiently in the
environment and in people and so never
do you have to send us off if you
explain what flag and how maybe just
give us a primer on letting lead is a
trace element in our environment some
people thought of heavy metal it is a
neurotoxin but it does not occur
naturally um and some neurotoxin means
that it affects the nervous system the
brain it is an element that once it's in
our environment it doesn't go anywhere
it's not soluble it's not mobile does
not biodegrade it does not reach reach
out into the groundwater so once its
present in our environment it stays
there for thousand because the two
thousand Spears hey Mark do you want to
add anything to that well I'm just
trying to think about the audience that
we're talking to here I think you know
if we try and think about sort of
toxicology 101 and by the way I'm not a
toxicologist I'm a veterinarian I'm the
clinician I play a toxicologist on TV
maybe but I'm not religious I know
enough to be dangerous but basically
there's an old statement that the dose
makes the poison that's not entirely
true but most things in large enough
quantities can be toxic and so we're
talking about things like lid that
occurred naturally in rocks in the
ground and that's in a class we
metals so wet mercury cadmium iron zinc
calcium raw metals then there's a whole
nother class that will be talking about
like BPA that are organic chemicals it
contain a lot of carbon in them many of
these are artificially produced by
people's activities thanks I'm just
enjoying us talking good about EPA is
cool yeah BPA probably couldn't be
different more different than led it is
an organic it is something that is made
by man it's made specifically as a
modeler to be used in the manufacture of
polycarbonate plastics these are the
hard plastic water bottles for a long
time she used in it as to make dental
resins and also to make the liner's a
lot of the canned foods that we get in a
grocery store and it is thought to be
these 10 hypotheses is that it's an
endocrine disruptor that is we get
enough of it in our body they can
interact with receptors such as the end
of the estrogen receptors and by doing
so can interact with the endocrine
system and cause toxicity and very
different than led this is a material
that when it gets in our body it does
not accumulate so we can be repeatedly
exposed to it and the blood
concentrations don't accumulate and if
we stop ingesting the material then our
blood concentrations will drop rapidly
and it entirely washes out of our body
in less than 24 hours so it's very
different very very short half five
short-acting material to organic
materials so it's kind of nice that we
can just oppose these these two
materials in the stocks that plots today
we're going to be jumping around from
all different kinds of questions I'm
going to take a question from one of our
readers already um let's see is it
possible for life to be absorbed through
the skin or two now this is from Alex
k10 and submitted honey house bed um not
not absorbed technically I'm certainly
not through the skin it's not good seat
imports in the most common way that
children and adults are exposed to light
with children it's more hand-to-mouth
activity so much for you qualify as much
as a child out playing in the soil you
know helping their parent
in the garden or you know just just out
playing with their cars and their toys
in the soil I'm in and they're putting
their hands in their mouth becoming
Afghans and their nose that's how
they're getting so so it's not not
absorbed as much as just congestion for
adults most common method of exposure is
in Malaysia so we as adults we're out
working in our garden and when we come
inside after being out in the garden we
usually wash our hands before we put our
hands anywhere near I'm Allison knows
but if we blow our nose after being out
memory that we often see is the nose are
our tissue is all around model soils at
dusk we've been healing when you're out
there to even realize oh so that's how
an adult would get those biskits
inhalation okay great um yes why I'm
cutting again I'm and we go one at a
time first with first we fled and what
does led do to the human body and what
amounts and how did we figure that out
oh I can start share market area here on
chime in so as I said lettuce and
neurotoxin which means it affects our
nervous system so they've been many many
studies over the years on the effect but
what has on the body so we know that it
lowers IQ of children it presents itself
with so sir abd and ADHD type symptoms
there have been studies that show that
it increases the hearing sensitivity
threshold there have been criminal
behaviors associated long terms of
long-term criminal behaviors associated
with people having elevated blood lead
levels there are some studies now that
say that some of the nervous system
disorders we're heading as older adults
are probably due to blood poisoning of
our youth because one of the things that
led does is it suppresses itself in our
bones because it's chemically similar to
calcium and then as we get older and
especially women respect your insides of
osteoporosis and our bones dr. grey but
when dispensa question in our bones all
these years starts to reach back out and
for once Kate screams and starts causing
problems in our and our old age as well
and mark do you see similar kinds of
effects in animals the bar now the
effects and animal species are amazing
Lee similar to what we see in people and
I think it's one of those really neat
things that shows us the evolutionary
linkages among all the vertebrate
species you know the enzymes that make
hemoglobin in our blood and that are
affected by leg or the way that nerves
are nerve transmission occurs is pretty
much the same in a fish as it is in a
bald eagle as it is in a child and so
you tend to get led affecting the same
systems in all these different species
if clinically it presents somewhat
differently I think that Samantha was
emphasizing the neurologic effects we
often see in children and certainly when
we see lead poisoning in bald eagles
they very frequently present unable to
stand with nervous tremors in other
species such as waterfowl ducks and
geese and swans we see more effects on
the digestive system and it affects the
the way that the digestive system
contracts peristalsis and often doesn't
allow these animals to digest their food
properly so there's some variation
between species in what we see clinics
and Destin do you want to talk about BPA
a little bit how what do we know about
probably affects people animals the
difference between us yeah I'm happy to
and this of course is a very
controversial question for bisphenol-a
and the answer kind of depends on which
of the science that you look at I could
say one thing about I don't have
variance of your question on how do we
know there have been lots of cohort
studies over the years looked at
children with high blood levels and then
followed them for many years to see what
happened I have examined them in
contrast to Jerusalem that you have had
local levels but for which everything
else is the same so that's how they if
they are both in very thin have
technology when you say a covert steady
what's the goal is there that's why
receiver I'm not everything go no um
don't finish my thought so if if we look
at the epidemiology letter turn there's
some micro yesterday some 61 studies are
so now that try to look at linkages
between BPA exposure and certain
environmentally related diseases such as
obesity and diabetes and things like
this there's a fairly consistent pattern
that's emerging but those the kinds of
studies that are being done can't tell
us that the BPA causes the effect it
only tells us essentially gives us a
hypothesis perhaps BPA causes these
effects in humans it's kind of where
things are with the EPI epidemiology now
we would sort of hope to use the the
toxicology studies in our road test
systems or vitro systems much the way
mark said that the physiology is similar
across a lot of these systems to human
so we think we can kind of trust them to
give us some idea of whether or not we
would expect to see the toxicities
receive animals humans in the animal in
cell culture data is fairly
controversial um I'll tell you the the
most recent study that I saw was an FDA
study that was conducted in rats this is
a really interesting study because they
gave bpa a huge range of doses to these
animals from low doses to really really
high doses by high I mean 300,000 times
higher than human exposure okay which is
it's just unusual actually to to give
animals that much material and what they
saw was that effectively at all the
doses within the human range and much
higher there really wasn't much talk to
see at all and they gave this material
to the animals and I think this will
interest people not for a short time but
they gave them to the animals while they
were pregnant the moms pregnant swall
that developing fetuses were exposed and
they when the pups were born right away
they gave it to the pots by World gavage
the same way we get they gave that
material too many these doses all the
way through maturity so it's a really
good study and they really didn't see
much toxicity and that kind of contrast
some of the
other studies have seen so it could be
in fact that that low-dose effects it
reported from EPA in some academic sort
of restricts kale studies are specific
to that kind of test system but maybe
aren't really what we expect to see in
humans so it's a little bit
controversial right now I think that's a
nice segue to a question from Barry and
Malin and this question is is it true
that's criminal cash register receipt
paper is a source of exposure to BPA and
you talk a little bit about whether and
you know about that and if so would it
be implications would be yeah so on that
of course is one of the dominant
questions right now I think in the
public and even in a scientific
community and I go back to something
that Samantha said because she kind of
nicely sort of laid out how we think
about exposure there can be exposure
outside of our body that's oftentimes
not the same level of concern as
exposure inside our body where our
tissues are that would react with the
material if you will so in the case of
bisphenol-a exposures and this this
issue of dermal receipts or receipts
that contain BPA um it is true that
those receipts some of them not all of
them some of them have fairly high
levels of BPA so there is the
possibility of getting that material on
your fingertips which does happen when
you handle the receipts but the next
question you have to ask is whether or
not after we get in on our fingertips
just like Glen does it actually go
through our skin end up in our body in a
level that can cause effects and here's
what we know that's pretty interesting
because BPA is pretty simple in this
regard we know that all the BPA were
exposed to that gets in our body comes
out in our urine so all we have to do is
collect the urine and we know just how
much BPA we were exposed to so when we
do that and not in a few people 100
people but when we do it in 30,000
people across 19 countries we get a
really clear answer and it says I'll
just use the number one it says get
about one BPA units when we look in food
and we figure out how much is in our
food it's also one two or three so what
we know is that what comes out of our
body is about the same as what
comes in from just food what that tells
this is there's really not a lot of room
for there to be another really
significant route of exposure or type of
exposure for EPA not only that but when
they've looked at the transfer of those
receipts the VPN receipts to skin it
happens but it looks like the majority
of that material doesn't cross over into
the body right now and so our current
thinking right now is that it is not a
significant source of internal exposure
to BPA but most importantly there are a
couple of studies that are looking at
this and people that handle cash
register receipt it's all day long and
those will be coming out pretty soon
what I can tell you from the pieces i've
seen is it doesn't look like we look in
the urine the constant exposure across
the day to these from say a cashier is
adding a whole lot to exposure but we'll
know better unfortunately great um I
want to remind our readers that you can
submit questions now they will pop up on
my screen I'll see them and I will try
to get to as many as you can um Matthews
don't crash asked a question and I mean
whatever you'd like to respond it would
be great and are there laboratory
testing techniques or perhaps methods of
analyzed the molecular structure that
can identify toxic chemicals before they
enter widespread use and this become
ubiquitous in the environment or is it
only after these materials up in and we
wearing them for years I did not data
exists to detect significance ah it's a
fabulous question I'll be interested to
see what we all say about it I my take
on that is that the state Oaks
analytical chemistry is very advanced at
this point compared to when I was in
school a million years ago and and that
we can identify will eat all of these
chemicals at exceedingly low levels um
in almost any substrate in the soil in
blood and urine saliva in anything else
and I think that the problem is not one
of analytical technique I think the one
the problem is a regulatory problem the
way that regulations are currently
written we're allowed to put many
chemicals into the
consumer stream into industrial use and
so forth without very much testing and
sometimes we have to wait decades and
begin to see effect before anybody asked
the question and goes back and looks so
I think for many people certainly many
of a clinical toxicologists I know they
would like to see a lot more free market
testing of these chemicals I agree with
mark and I think the other thing is it
is totally regulatory and it's also
expensive shoe oh and I think the other
thing that we don't but we think about
but having dealt with as a synergistic
effects of chemical so it's not simply
nothing but that's the one thing that
we're going to use next but thinking
about how is this a new thing we may be
foreign gardener going to interact with
everything else that we didn't just came
by me over the years and so when you add
that it it takes the magnitude of the
testing that would need to happen and
just increases opponents in bath me give
an example of the kind of dinner just
take one of those that might be enough
cleaning of that convenience there well
certainly I think that there have you
might extra pieces of having other still
sticking with that and I think maybe
Justin the market for the dresses as
well but certainly I think if we have
led in our bodies and then we start
adding some of the other heavy metals it
that someone that gave those to cadmium
arsenic mercury some of those are also
neurotoxins some that carcinogens and so
of course they're both affecting our
bodies individually and what the
weakening of your body one of those
metals is due to the ability of the
other metal too so I certainly agree
with eight what they've said and I think
I'll try to extend the answer a little
bit and and say that this is really one
of the most exciting areas in the film
of toxicology and I would say actually
computational toxicology right now so
that the question was you know it's sort
of a way we can identify these two
structures it might chemicals it might
be more problematic than others we've
had some real of successes in the field
of toxicology for example on the dioxins
and the PCBs if I if I if I kids were
front of me I have three wonderful boys
if they were in front of me and I drew
out these structures of dioxin it would
look a particular way it has to be flat
like this for it to be active in biology
and then the chemists and the
toxicologists learned that it molecule
can twist a little like this doesn't
work so well and so they kind of drew
out all these relationships made them
very quantitative and now we know it can
be given almost staining the PCBs and
dioxins and we can kind of make a pretty
good guess as to whether or not they're
going to be really toxic this finale is
another good example in the sense that
if I drew up estrogen epa's and estrogen
mimic and I drew out EPA anybody out
there would probably look at them go all
those are pretty similar so the field is
actually growing rapidly in this area
and it's obviously not as simple as I
just described it but the chemists are
working with the computational people
and they're essentially learning to
describe every little aspect of
molecules the oxygens the carb is and
how they're structured for you know
thousands of chemicals and then they do
high-throughput testing in cells and
they see what effects they have and they
try to connect up little aspects of the
various chemical structures to those
activities so that in fact as the reader
is the the writer said or asked can we
actually predict what the effects might
be and I the short answer i'll give is i
have a lot of hope that that will be
really effective for small classes of
compounds like the oxidants or like
materials that look like estrogen or
that look like testosterone or maybe
chemical or let metals that look exactly
like LED for all chemicals more of a
challenge but this is really exciting
because if we can tie that to the
regulatory aspect of this then we have a
much higher probability of getting rid
of the materials that are going to be
problematic before they find their way
into our products you know this is an
area of great help i think at one point
that i think you made it's really
important is i think a lot of the
answers here a computational rabbit and
toxicological because if you think about
it and and certainly your video program
has covered this with other sorts of
chemicals all of us are living in sort
of a chemical suit on the face of the
earth they've been naturally occurring
things in the air we breathe and water
we drink
the chemicals that are produced by human
activities metals inorganic chemicals
organic chemicals that we all have
summon up we all have a little bit of
DDT in our body we all had dioxin on our
body we all have bisphenol-a in our body
and then there's other subtle things you
know we know for instance with lead
poisoning whether it's in people or
animals that the nutritional status of
the person can affect their ability to
absorb the lead and up and the harm 0
level cause the stress and the stress
hormones produced by the adrenal glands
can affect the ability of lead to affect
the body drugs that one takes
therapeutically can affect many of these
different chemicals and so I think one
of the challenges you know if you go to
the doctor now and you're on several
medications they can look in a computer
and they can say well if we add this new
medication is interactions between the
medications we don't want you to be on
this medication a mountain together now
we need to be able to ask that if not
just medications but these environmental
chemicals that were exposed to in a much
more complex fashion and I think that's
what computational analysis is so
important that we have a question that
relates to an tracking the movements of
chemicals and with involving hydraulic
fracturing in groundwater and and I know
that's not focusing on here but I wanted
to you know if you'd like to address
that sure but I'd like to draw a bigger
question out of that which is um what
techniques technology is exist and are
being developed to to track the movement
of blood of BPA how do we find the fist
stuff aside from helping individuals
Jenny your sneeze or turn on in my area
certainly with lead and other heavy
metals they can often be tracked the
source so there's lots of work that's
been done that show that the various
metals um they are it's there's there's
some predictability in terms of how
close they are to source and that
compensation increases as you increase
your distance allergic source so heavy
metals are
a lot of work that's been done pizza for
the lab we often see blood
concentrations fire two roads because
back of the put a leaded gasoline when I
open up your tailpipe and then it would
fairly certain drop back down into the
soil exposing the road as you look
further further inroads in many cases
for low concentrations decreased we know
that lead concentrations are often
higher closer to houses that were paper
than what they think who things like
cadmium even you know that academy
reviews in batteries caddy and reused in
tanneries you know so we can again look
at the industrial history of certain
areas and even a residential district of
certain areas and predict what we think
we might see so that that's what I don't
know if anything about mark so that's
leaded gasoline but that's not okay
we're walking a little bit earlier about
another way that that gets into the
environment which is through through
hunting you talk about that sure well
one of the things that I connect again I
think we've talked about this with other
chemicals like BPA there's multiple
sources and you know the body doesn't
differentiate one source of lead from
another source of lead and as you were
saying earlier the body accumulates led
over time if you ingest led from any
source if it's breathed in from fumes or
if it's you're in you food or any other
sort of thing and it we can measure
blood left pretty easily but the lead
only stays in your blood in people a
couple of weeks and then it goes slowly
you excrete some in the urine and feces
some then goes into the soft tissues the
liver and the kidneys but all that ends
up as samantha saint in the bones lead
follows calcium body and lead can stay
in people's bones for decades and there
is technology XRF technology where we
can actually measure lead in bones of
live people you know just by holding a
little sensor against their skin it's
expensive and fermentation but it's
really cool i wish we'd get it more in
animals um but what that means is you
could have the same amount of lead in
your body from one big exposure or from
multiple little exposures and I think in
MA
in human society at least in developed
countries like we're living in now we
don't get single big exposures very much
except for some occupational sources but
for you and me you know living around
it's the little exposures over time that
add up and add up in your body that can
have long-term effects so it's a little
bits of lead from here a little bits of
lead from there and the sources we were
talking about I'll protect particularly
for people who use lead in recreational
activities and this is the things I
worked on are mostly having to do with
sporting goods with hunting and fishing
gear we stopped using lead for hunting
waterfowl in this country we did that
better than 20 years ago for a variety
of reasons we were poisoning a lot of
waterfowl and poisoned a lot of bald
eagles with that but still most of the
shot and bullets manufactured in this
country are left and if you think about
let think about not just the product
whether it's paint or gasoline or the
bullet think about it's a life cycle
it's in Iraq in the soil it's in galena
or one of the ores of leg we have to get
the rock out with the minor to grind the
rock out we could melt it and smelt it
make it into products and so there are
pollutants getting into the environment
low levels of let it every step in the
process and even if you look at things
that are recycled for instance
automobile batteries typical automobile
battery contains about 10 pounds of left
now in the u.s. currently ninety-five
percent of automobile batteries are
recycled and we feel great about that
one of the problems is where they
recycled they recycled in India and
Indonesia and Kazakhstan and Mexico and
they're recycled in places where people
have very low levels of Technology and
very poor worker protective laws and
we're poisoning a lot of people around
the world even as we try and be good and
recycle the lid and Samantha and I would
have a meeting yesterday where there
were a bunch of speakers on land of
course one of the things is there's the
object like the bullet or the shot but
when you recycle that oftentimes there's
fumes that go up into the atmosphere and
so if you're melting lead in Jakarta
Indonesia the fumes are going up into
the atmosphere and they're coming down
in the rain in the United States and in
Europe so
truly global problem and we need to see
many of these pollutants as global
problems that we need global solutions
as you say it's different from p pa ya
pa pa has such a short half-life whereas
Len once you create it's going to be
there for the next 10,000 years or more
you know the speaker asked the third
question the speaker asked you know
reminds me that the public has a huge
appetite for understanding their
exposures yeah they mentioned the
context of fracking um but the same
question is true for lots of other
contexts and I think what's really
exciting right now I think is that
people are beginning to recognize that
we're really short on exposure data so
when it comes to fracking the question
was how do we know what we're being
exposed to how can you track the stuff
than environment and I think there's
some really exciting work that's being
conducted across the country the pacific
northwest national average does a lot of
work making widgets that measure things
sensors very sophisticated small sensors
that can be placed in the environment or
used in the clinic lots of institutions
are working on this what should be
exciting to the listeners is it is this
field grows it should be pretty possible
to place these sensors in the
environment I should say this is being
done now yeah so that they can actually
track the flows of some of these
materials the organics maybe even the
meds and things yeah over time in these
in the fracking scenario maybe near new
smelters that are supposed to be clean
whatever the scenario is that's what's
exciting to me they're even hooking
these things up to iphones down yeah so
that they can actually air sample and
tell us how much knocks and socks you're
exposed to as you walk down the street
match that to mappings and people get a
real-time idea what they're being
exposed to so that's kind of the
exciting future i think for for people
to understand okay so i have another
question which sums like some of the
questions we got online they're all
giving to the question that it's really
natural health how do we protect
ourselves from various kinds of toxins
and maybe it took it included um your
take on that I would be curious to know
for any given
the fall what would be your procedure
first for determining how much I should
worry about it and then that's the point
that I know what should i do what should
I do next what may I think first people
need to educate themselves right they
need to know what's out there and what
they're being exposed do I think a lot
of people don't think about whether
whether a lot of it is out of sight out
of mind maybe if I don't think about
venom you can worry about it we had
somebody in that session yesterday that
said I'm from California and I eat
organic food but I've never thought
about the fact that there could be heavy
metals in the soil where they're going
my organic food do they test you that
and the answer is no organic customers
not tested any medicine so something
that you have never thought about before
and the most citizens will not think
about that you think organic it's
wonderful I don't worry about anything
I'm even organic food so I think the
first thing that citizens need to do is
to educate themselves about what's out
there but what they're being exposed to
go about what's in there their
environments near their homes and then I
think there is there with the things
like metals there are some simple things
that you can do um you know test
yourself that's what I tell people all
the time if you're going to have
children exposed to soil in your
backyard we're going to have backyard
chickens if you're going to be growing
bodies in your backyard and you live in
an urban area test it off test test test
rural areas as well as much of a concern
make sure you wash your hands I mean
there are some very simple things that
can be done in many situations in terms
of how much is too much I mean I think
there's a lot of literature out there
for specific contaminant again about the
levels that we consider acceptable again
what that doesn't do is to look at
synergistic effects and what's happening
if you've got multiple exposures and
i'll let you definitely certainly some
of the concerns i think are already
appreciated by people for instance in
the real estate industry you know if
you're going to buy a house you should
make sure that it's been tested for lead
especially if it's a house built before
1978 many towns across the country do
annual water quality tests which tests
not only
for bacteria but we'll test for a
variety of heavy metals and I know in
the town i live in every year we get a
report read those reports go and talk to
the people in your town Public Health
Department find out what's going on
there you can look at maps of Superfund
sites you can look at maps of toxic
sites generated by state conservation
organizations most states have those
online at this point to see where
potential industrial pollutants sites
whether their current sites or historic
sites are in your state find out where
those are so again I think a Samantha
saying educating ourselves is probably
the best thing yes it's an immensely
challenging problem and it comes back
again to the need for exposure science
which is nothing I keep repeating you
know for any person that actually wants
to understand sort of the totality of
their exposure to chemicals there's
really kind of a dearth of information
on there we're starting to develop the
methods to actually understand take a
single blood sample and maybe report on
a hundred or a thousand different
chemicals that are in your blood but if
you give that information to most people
if you gave that information to me i'm a
board-certified toxicologist iowa myself
would had a bit of a challenge if not an
immense challenge in understanding what
that meant to my personal health and
which of that list of chemicals i should
actually invest the time and energy to
avoid I think as they suggested mark and
Samantha you can look to the regulatory
agencies but oftentimes there isn't
something you can look up this is your
blood level is this so you need to avoid
that because even if it's in your blood
where to come from which thing do you
avoid the can do you avoid going outside
to not cook fish anymore do you not cook
meat anymore so I wish we had an easy
answer but it's it's an immensely
difficult problem yeah I think one of
the things that many people are looking
for you know given the complexity of
toxicology is we're looking for indirect
ways to assess the effect of multiple
toxins on biological systems and
certainly the biomedical scientists are
always looking for this magic bio
indication you know can we look at
something in the
endocrine system can we look at
something in the immune system you know
the behavior of our white cells in a
petri dish when they're exposed to serum
or something that will give us a sense
of the additive effects of all the
things in our bodies and again we're not
there yet science isn't there yet but
people are looking very hard there that
sort of thing I think I think it's
something that happens is that it can
become very overwhelming so as young
hate themselves and you leave some of
the popular press books here we know
there are some great books written by
scientists that have been written for
everyday citizens that are wonderful way
is to begin to educate yourselves but
what happens is it becomes overwhelming
the people have shut down and they say
oh my god I don't know how I would ever
be able to do any of this and we have to
we have to not let that happen we have
to you know we have to be proactive and
not become overwhelmed and really be
engaged through our legislators and
government and working for words in our
environment in it it really is policy to
marginal policy and that link between
the science of the policy and getting
people engaged Samantha I was wondering
the three of us here the three panelists
I guess our parents in my case I've
gotten to be grandparents in the last
few years which feels weird but I'm
wonderful but you know I'm wondering if
any of us when we're thinking about our
own families are we doing things at home
we're supposed to be a toxicological e
savvy what what have we done in our
homes are with our families yeah I guess
my answer to that is that my my primary
focus is on the nutrition side yeah and
encouraging my young boys to eat their
vegetables and fruit as part of a
healthy diet we grow some vegetables in
the backyard the kids enjoy on we try to
keep a broad diet I cannot say that I
spend a lot of time trying to figure out
how to avoid toxicants in our food
supply I think I do spend a little bit
of time trying to avoid bacterial
sources of bacteria in our food supply
which is a which is really a source of
major risk in the food supply across the
world
and I have to admit to being somewhat
reliance on the fact that the United
States has one of the safest food
supplies in the world um and I don't
worry too much about it more about the
nutrition sign I don't know how you guys
yeah yeah well I think everybody has
their own little paranoia you know I my
paranoia and I i think my daughters are
sick of hearing this is I try and get
them not to heat their food in the
microwave in a plastic container I think
that you know there are enough chemicals
in plastics it can be transferred into
foods depending on the ph and things
that i worry about those sorts of things
i have friends who are very careful
about using you know activated charcoal
water filters in their homes I don't
currently do that because we have pretty
good town water testing yeah but i think
the nutrition side is tremendously
important in this and sometimes the
choices people make to avoid certain
foods because they feel that there might
be contaminants in them can lead to some
pretty serious implications on nutrition
side as well yeah well as an example I
mean you mentioned testing and US food
supplies and I can give you an example I
have a friend acacia also VAR Warren who
is a shrimp biologist and worked on
shrimp that are farmed most of the ship
we buy in the supermarket these days are
farmed in developing countries very few
were a wild card anymore for a whole
variety of reasons and one of the
alarming things that she did was she
took our veterinary students had our
veterinary students go out to several
local supermarkets buy shrimp bring him
back and test them and you know we don't
test the imported food very much for
anything and so there was some you know
a few minor bacterial diseases but the
levels of heavy metals in the shrimp
we're terrified and I don't eat them
anymore yeah a few of you know but this
is this is that dose makes the poison
you don't want to live on shrimp yeah so
we've been talking about this a little
bit i'm going to read a question that
relates to what we're discussing and
from read and read out a problem in the
environmental health areas that everyone
wants to be reassured the chemicals in
food and consumer products are safe but
you don't have adequate scientific tools
to really assess that people are often
prize to learn common chemicals are not
evaluated for safety before they are
sold and we have made many serious
mistakes EG led the city's asbestos i
think the public is tired of hearing
with chemicals and products might be
dangerous and not knowing what to do it
seems we need to do something different
what would that be so we've been talking
about this a little bit on in the
household level um and we brought a
regulation earlier um wait dude no I
understand she's a voice of reason it
was a great question to ask and I I
would hope that we'd find very few
people who wouldn't agree with her
comment that it's in the best interest
of Public and Environmental Health both
to have a better process of testing
chemicals before they reach into
Commerce and i think one fan i would
also acknowledge that there's a funding
challenge there and it costs a
tremendous amount of money to actually
test all these materials on although
that it doesn't mean that some more
pressure shouldn't be put on some people
to test these materials but i guess
there has to be some hope put into
high-throughput testing and some of the
quantitative structure-activity
relationships and we've talked about and
also looking which probably isn't done
enough at the potential for
environmental release an accumulation
and one of these materials transport
environment so that we could scrape off
the top the materials that look like
they'd be most toxic or look like they
would actually transport widely in the
environments were accumulating divided
these sorts of things i think i think
there's every reason to try to do more
of that kind of testing for sure and i'd
like to see that happen part of it and
we get away from science and into
sociology and economics and marketing
things where I know very little again
just enough to be dangerous but I think
one of the questions with products is
are they really necessary you know are
we introducing something just because we
want novelty and because it's going to
get a little larger piece of the market
share and thus we introduce a new
fragrance or an artificial color or
something like that
we don't know the effects or are we
introducing a product because it
generally benefits people and it will
solve a real problem and that's a
situation that I really don't know the
answer to but it's I think it's a good
question to discuss what Mark said what
I was thinking is working does when
you're talking is is there another way
to exceed the same goal and I and I
don't that and oftentimes these other
ways are more expensive and they may not
be as easy but I don't think about that
in terms of alternative product design
is are there any groups or research here
seeking are really exciting or losing
that direction that you can get the
attention to oh I think you know as a
college professor I see things all the
time I see students now you know after
the BP a scare now all of our students
carry around their water in mason jars
that's not particularly safe if you're
carrying around glass containers so now
they knit cozies for their class
containers so I think you know there are
always alternatives we can screw the
circular always find wonderful thanks
email like you say I mean I'm good mark
in my house I don't things up in plastic
and you most certainly we don't need to
it was always handy to be able to do
that handy to be able to posting
something in plastic and stick it
refrigerator and then but um I think
that there are all kinds of green
companies out there that are coming up
with alternatives for things now again
not for everything but for a lot of the
household items that we have and so
plastics have come up a lot in this
conversation we wanted talking about
them and there's a there's a question
specifically on from alex kay chen on
what plastics and plastic white products
are known / thought to have here toxic
top news specifically he asks and what
what about styling from styrofoam I'll
show that one over to the park for fall
interesting gonna be on my area of
expertise right now I don't have an
answer to that one either okay um we're
we do where would you go to find out if
you were Alex we need to out
or I might start with union of concerned
scientists I think they have some
information turn me on their website and
that their main office down here that
would at least start you on the road
where else a primary literature there's
lots i'm sure there's lots of primary
literature that describes on various
plastic products out there and whether
or not through leeches from them mmm and
what those materials can't do hopefully
hopefully the person can put whatever
the findings are the context of exposure
but you can actually look at this
question sort of through the lens of BPA
because there has been this movement to
replace BPA for example in the hard
polycarbonate plastic bottles that we
all used to have on with new materials
sure polystyrene material tonight I
think I'm right in saying that um in the
best of circumstances the replacement
materials as fan Radel suggested would
be tested yeah um at least as thoroughly
as BPA has been for example and my
understanding is that number of the
potential replacement plastics have not
been thoroughly tested so here's a case
where we've actually removed one thing
for commerce whose public health risk is
questionable with another one where the
question is simply we don't know at all
on that that's another challenge that we
face is just replacing things with
materials that we don't know if they're
safe or not very well me yeah and it is
a balance of risk and I think Samantha
made this good point glass is pretty
safe you know from the point of view of
toxicology glass is pretty cheap we can
all melts and but it has other dangers
you know it drops at rated sharp i cut
myself the other day so how do we do the
risk assessment you know the cost
benefit analysis on all these sorts of
things and i would bring it back to the
point I made earlier on the question of
life cycle with all of these things
whether it's sand trick glass whether
it's oh the chart is not working we're
running on reserve power we have to look
at our computer firm oh okay bugs to
your plums the weird because it
okay we're just going to move this
assuming that Shane Matz will get
straightened out did the one for the
right Mac make sure you know I wonder
there you gotta go check every jerk yeah
perfect we got the light back congested
we're good like we are technologically
plug it in the expertise existed so
various Bibles you but but i think this
life cycle question come you know if you
think about plastics plastics are
virtually all made of petroleum products
so getting the petroleum products out of
the ground shipping them around the
world in super tankers refining them
making them into plastics all have
environmental and health costs and so we
have to think not just to the final
product whether it's a mason jar or a BB
a plastic container or a lead bullet we
need to think of the environmental cost
of the whole thing including disposal
and recycling and here's a question that
it is interesting and are there any
natural substance is known to have your
a toxic effect well I think and Samantha
started out with that I think many of
the metals mm-hmm go to the CDC website
go to the CDC website and you look on
their lead poisoning page it says you
know any time you have a combination of
the following three clinical signs
neurologic effects gastrointestinal
effects and anemia any combination of
those you should think that it's a heavy
metal it's the first place you should go
it could be mercury it could be cadmium
it could be arsenic it could be
LED but those are all natural chemicals
that occur in the Earth's crust isn't
under also a lot of plants that Oh for
example yellow start this whole another
absolutely yeah there's a lot of animal
toxins that are balanced against and you
know I'll to drag this into the vpa area
as well because we talked about
endocrine disruption and BPA is an
estrogen mimic and so you the the writer
might ask the question are there also
natural materials that are estrogenic
and the answer that is absolutely on the
soy products have these things called
isoflavone if I drew out that little
chemical structure from my kids when I
drew out estrogen they would look at
them and say that they're the same they
look very similar one other so
chemically very similar and they are
estrogenic and by the tools and
techniques we have now they're in some
cases more estrogenic than BPA and they
are in our blood and in fact you can
actually go out and buy these in some of
the natural food stores as food
supplements and they'll suggest that you
take absolutely massive doses of
genistein and apparently that's that's
not of concern to people but but the
point is the same kinds of activities
that you expect from a week
estrogen-like EPA you can find a natural
products and my point is not to suggest
that that there's no problem with bpa my
point is just to say that the writer was
right these things are present in our
food supply from natural sources as well
and sometimes I think the right question
to ask is sort of what's the totality of
the estrogenic load from chemicals from
our diet whether they're natural or not
cuz that's more important than the
question of what is the estrogenic load
from one chemical and I think that goes
back to synergism and the idea of you
know if there's multiple metals that are
neurotoxic in our diet do we just want
to look at lead or are we more
interested in all of them together but I
think it's a very savvy question it's
one that everybody should be thinking
about so you're saying I should be
microwaving tofu in no no actually I
won't say that because that
zooms that those things are dangerous
for you in fact there's certainly health
benefits for you to be eating tofu I
think everybody would probably recognize
that great well as I do I think we've
covered all of the questions from our
audience so I think we're going to start
to wrap up is um there anything else
that you would like to add final final
thoughts for our discussion there's so
many where do we begin yeah yeah one of
the things that I would like to say is
that the people listening in the public
at large certainly have choices that
they make about where they get their
information about chemicals that they're
exposed to and what that actually means
and I would just suggest that they be
very cautious when they look on the web
and read inflammatory or lawyering
things that are red because it just
takes one or two people with a
particular opinion about something to
actually make people fear chemicals in
their diet in their environment I would
also argue that they avoid listening to
one or two scientists who suggest that
any particular chemical is not a problem
and instead turn to the regulatory
bodies and international panels of
experts to get together and make
statements as a group of professionals
about whether or not things are a
problem or not because I think there is
a lot of misinformation engenders out
there come through in that particular
media that people need to be aware of
they can be misled very easily people
are getting more savvy they understand
that but I would encourage people to be
very cautious with that I think the
other thing I'm thinking about the
audience that we may be talking to that
I hope we're talking to here I hope
there are a lot of young people in the
audience who may be thinking about what
career tracks very interested in taking
and I think look at the three of us you
know we have a board of toxicologist we
have a clinical veterinarian we have a
soil scientist all with common interests
now all with very different backgrounds
but all working in an interdisciplinary
to look at these large environmental and
health issues and I think that's where
the solutions lie no one profession has
all the answers that is really it's
working together and getting all these
brains with all these different you know
sets of training to talk together and to
exchange ideas into some kind of
disagree and have arguments and come up
with new data is the way that science
works in the way that this all
progresses and so no matter what the
interests of these young people are I
think there are ways that they can make
important contributions you like to add
I think that people make decisions or
choices as consumers every day and I
think those choices that people make as
consumers companies listen to and so I
think that you know we all know that
changes have been made in our society
and Washington through public outcry so
I think you know just to say to people
make make good choices as consumers and
start talking about what my new shoes
are become engaged and that I guess
that's that oh but that's a very
important very important thing to do and
and people politicians listen when
people speak in volumes and as well
thank you so much for and to our guests
for joining nothing and two readers for
submitting such great questions and this
is our last you will hang out from the
triple-a s conference so really fun and
will be once again resuming our Thursday
flying's live chats next week um so come
find us on Frank flag and thanks again
you